breaking in stars Gabrielle Union as a
mother trying to protect her two
children a son and a daughter from
robbers who have invaded her recently
deceased father's house they're there
because they want something in the house
and it's a very well protected place
there's tons of security cameras
automatic locks alarm systems a gate and
she gets trapped outside of the house
while the robbers are inside with her
children and she has to actually break
into the house to try to save her
children that's sort of the reversal of
what you see in movies like panic room
which is a far better film than breaking
in because this movie really feels like
it belongs in the straight-to-dvd bin
which is very strange because this film
is directed by James motika man who made
V for Vendetta
one of my favorite comic book movies
ever and every film he's made since then
ninja assassin survivor the Raven and
now this show none of the talent or
expertise that was on display in V for
Vendetta which is very curious to me
according to IMDB this movie is 88
minutes long and that's including the
end credits there's also an elongated
opening sequence that's almost entirely
in slow motion that doesn't really need
to be in the film and that opening feels
like it's setting up a far more complex
film than the one we actually receive
the backstory seems to be the Gabrielle
union's father had a bad relationship
with her we never really learned why
there's very little that explores this
it's just that he became I guess a
reclusive man very paranoid with
something stashed away in his house and
a lot of alarms and we're supposed to
feel like there's something going on
under the surface when all it really is
is a very rote and derivative thriller
the best part of the film by far is
Gabrielle unions performance she's very
good she does quite a bit of physical
stuff and all of the emotional scenes
she does a fantastic job she seems like
she's really trying in fact she has a
producer credit on this film so she was
integral in its development as well the
leader of this gang of robbers is played
by billy burke also known as the best
part of every Twilight movie he's giving
a performance that's very curious to me
he feels sort of like he's just annoyed
his character
doesn't want to be there things aren't
going properly for him he's annoyed by
the incompetence of his fellow teammates
as well as basically everything that
happens but he's so passive about it
that the stakes never feel that real he
just doesn't feel like he's a presence
to be feared it seems like he's trying
to play it in a way where he's this cold
calculating individual who never shows
that much emotion who only does what
needs to be done but it doesn't come off
that way it comes off as bored like he
doesn't really want to be there one of
the biggest issues I have with the film
is what it does with the children since
Gabrielle Union is outside and her kids
are inside
they're the pawns they're the pieces
that these robbers are able to move
around to create tension between
themselves and Gabrielle Union they're
the bait they're what keep her at bay
they're what keep her from running off
and calling the police and they're the
only reason she's still there because
obviously the film sets up that she
doesn't really care that much about her
deceased father and so there's even a
scene where she's like hey just take the
money and leave I don't care just let me
have my kids and the robbers are like no
you don't trust you the movie would have
ended right then if they trusted her but
this film requires that children to be
in danger but they're really not for
most of the movie they're regulated to
one room for pretty much the entire film
and they don't interact with the robbers
that much they're basically just in that
room for the majority of the movie and
so the sense of danger for their lives
is very minimal because they're hardly
ever in it they're mostly locked in a
room the whole film so let's talk about
the Edit of breaking in because
surprisingly I have a lot to say let's
push your side the technical part of
editing first and focus on censorship
because there are a lot of scenes in the
movie where characters seem to mouth the
f-word and it's replaced with freaking
there were moments where it played like
a movie that had been edited for
television with any harsh violence or
language edited out to achieve a pg-13
rating now let's talk about the
technical part of editing this film
feels very loose and I don't mean that
in a positive way
it feels like the film needed at least
two or three more passes but it's
already under 90 minutes and that's with
an opening sequence in slow motion that
stretches out the runtime even more so
much of this
he feels very slow and methodical and I
don't mean this again in a positive way
almost every shot goes on for longer
than you would expect it to and it
really drags out the pacing of the film
and it just becomes a game of
cat-and-mouse that isn't particularly
compelling I am blown away that James
motika this film because as I said it
shows none of the innovation none of the
technical mastery that's on display in V
for Vendetta
and yet the film does have a very smart
hero and Gabrielle Union who actually
makes refreshingly smart choices she's
not an idiot in fact there's another
character in the film at one point could
have made a really terrible decision but
she makes a really smart one and I was
like okay this actually doesn't feel
like we're watching really dumb horror
movie characters so that's probably one
of the major pluses of the film combined
with unions performance but besides that
this is just a very throwaway disposable
thriller tailor-made for the Mother's
Day period and I just don't understand
how James Mattia was involved in this
movie it really does feel like anyone
could have directed this I'm gonna give
breaking-in a D+ guys thank you so much
as always for watching stay tuned for
more reviews very soon including my
review of psycho I can't wait to bring
that to you as always thank you so much
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]
[Applause]